[Music]
[Applause]
all right hand Corrections this is a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show we invite them to
try to find a mistake on our show so far
millions of challengers not one winner
will make mistakes just don't do it nope
well tonight a fan named kitten caboodle
7 says she thinks she caught a mistake
she says it happened during our episode
that featured the entire cast of The Big
Bang Theory hi Conan do you had the
entire cast of Big Bang Theory on it was
wonderful when they were talking about
knowing Klingon they could only think of
one word and that was pon farr meaning
sex I mean didn't they assume you could
speak Klingon
it does mean sex but it's not Klingon
it's Vulcan so y'all got it wrong
[Music]
why does she know that well I'm very
sorry kitten caboodle seven but it is
you who are mistaken now we looked into
it sure the word pon Fahr is a Vulcan
word true but anyone up on their Star
Trek lore knows it was originally a
Klingon word that ended up in the Vulcan
vernacular if you don't believe me check
out this scene from the original Star
Trek it only aired once back in 1966 at
8:30 p.m. on NBC it hasn't been seen
since but ladies and gentlemen children
watching learned a lot that night take a
look
ha ha ha Klingon Val conga mom we hunt
but those nailers who please damu tell
cookie Hodge a cold ocean of poo HD
attract n or slit and
he's a La Loma East ah so Mata Tata
[Music]
so the tone still stands if you think
you spotted an era on our show reporter
team koco.com / haha I found it ever we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro let's
go
you